here's what I'd like you to do just hide
that blue graph for a second so just tap
on the UM on the circle over here so it
disappears you can get rid of this
slider if you like we're going to not
need it for now and now instead of
having a polynomial right X to the power
of a theme X is a power of some number
okay what I want us to do is reverse
that okay so we want to have not X to
the power of something but something to
the power of X now that's something is
gonna be really important I want to muck
about with it a little bit so in here
I'm gonna put in just the letter A
that's gonna be my base down here okay
we'll add a slider in a second but just
back on this keyboard this is the button
you want to get to the power or you
could've done the Hat button on your
keyboard if you like it's up the top now
and I want to make X the exponent there
okay now I'm gonna add my slider all
right now before we muck about and slide
this thing around
what is this graph right now this is
what graph is this have a look have a
look at a particular value of a desmos
winning when you ask for a slider Dez
must always default to this value
so at the moment is a equals 1 so this
is 1 to the power of X so it's just one
all the way that's why it's a horizontal
line yeah makes sense ok here's what I
like us to do change that value or
rather change this um go to this little
cog up above here and you can see in
here you can change the domain of a the
values that a is allowed to take for the
purposes of illustration what I'd like
us to do is make the lower boundary one
and the top boundary five should do it
so put a 1 in there on the left and then
put a 5 over there on the right you got
that does that make sense right so I got
to I got to this screen by hitting the
cog and then I can press that and press
done now I get this okay
so does yours look like mine now you see
before we had a negative 10 in 10 those
was that was our domain for a now I've
got one in 5 gave me a thumbs up if you
got that yep okay now you've got that
now please go ahead and play with a
change it and see what happens
so this is say it against rain this is
an exponential curve right we've got X
in the exponent that's why we call this
as an exponential curve and you can see
what happens is as the value of ay
increases you get an exponential curve
it's kind of well it's steeper over here
and it's shallower over here okay it's
dancing around all right very good now
what I'd like you do is just um hit
pause and I'm take a put it somewhere
around to two will do it for us okay
that's close enough for me all right now
remember we looked at x squared X cubed
x to power four and we look at its
derivatives
I had deliberately asked you to hide the
derivative here we're going to bring it
back in a second but before you do that
I want you to think with me how would
you describe the gradient of this
function as it changes over time is it
positive is negative it's changed can
someone tell me anything about the
gradient function of this say it again
okay so let me take that phrase a
constant gradient increase so I want to
sort of unpack that right I'm gonna
start at the end actually what do you
mean by gradient increase actually I'm
gonna uh someone else what they think
Sarah means why would he use a phrase
like gradient increase okay I think
Ben's exactly right this thing gets
steeper and steeper and steeper as you
go along so we should be expecting our
gradient to be increasing that constant
question is a bit harder to answer isn't
it because you're like how much is it
increasing over time like I'm not
instinctively sure like I can't eyeball
that and say oh I know it's going to be
going up this much or that much but I
think we agree it's increasing can
someone tell me is the gradient negative
or zero or positive what can you tell me
about it about its sign hmm go back do
you remember when I had on extra power
form on here remember that guy right and
then we saw when you had this side of X
to the power of 4 the graph was going
down right and what did that tell you
about the derivative the derivative was
negative right are there any parts of
this graph that are going down and so no
so I shouldn't have I shouldn't expect
any parts of the derivative to be
negative
are there are any parts that are flat
that a state better stationery points
any spots
is there any spot where it's like boom
I'm not moving anywhere I'm not going
down
I think wills is things right I'm giving
a shake of the head ish now what are you
thinking everything what do you mean by
everything after zero that's a count
Sophie what are you thinking you're
saying I want to unpack this phrase here
because this is interesting to me okay
so that you're actually both using
different language to look at the same
thing just want to come back to Sophie's
phrase so V said that the gradients
approaching zero
where were you referring to that Sophie
no no no I I think it's important I just
want to know where like yeah okay so if
you're reading from right to left right
if you zoomed in fact go ahead and do
this now zoom in on the left-hand side
of the graph right if you zoom in far
enough it starts to look like it's
really really shallow do you notice that
right it's not exactly horizontal do you
agree I'm you can try and get quite
close to horizontal go further and
further to the left but it never gets
there exactly okay all right now what we
all did was we hid this derivative
function do you ever that okay can you
make it reappear just hit that circle
and that blue graph will come back okay
do you have this is this what you've got
you up the tree there
okay so we've got our red graph which is
through the power X roughly and then
you've got this derivative which is just
beneath it do you see that so far so
good okay so what are we observing
you've got this exponential function the
red one and it's derivative is another
exponential function just think about
that for a second this is kind of
unusual because when we had a look at
those previous functions right when you
differentiated something like x squared
what did it become 2x very good
so a parabola turned to a straight line
when you differentiated yeah then when
we had a look at the cubic why don't we
get as a derivative this time 3x squared
very good so this cubic shape the sort
of like weird sneaky looking thing it
got a whole new show
when we look at its derivative it became
a parabola right but when you have a
look at the exponential function it
doesn't do that it doesn't turn to a
whole new kind of graph it just kind of
turns it to a different version of
itself does that make sense okay now
just like before and I'm not going to do
it this time on the screen I want you to
do it I'll start starting the other
question you sure all right so that's
right good come back to us just like
before I'd like you to slide around a
can you do that please on your screen I
want you to slide it around I'm not
gonna do it up here I want you to do it
and I want you to tell me if you notice
anything unusual what did you notice I'm
just letting it play now did you notice
it was kind of like a special value of a
somewhere in between here you should
notice that let me just hit pause back
at XA equals two sorry it's hard to be
precise on an iPad that'll do about
there no there we go bang on we noticed
in this case here's our red function our
original ones derivative was just
beneath it did you notice that an
exponential was just beneath but at a
certain point for example if you went to
equals three just slide it up there
yellow hold on a second our blue graph
which is our derivative it's no longer
below my exponential where is it
it's just above all the way along it's
just above just above just so some of
you might notice somewhere between two
and three there's this magic spot where
it lines up try and get it close right
if you want to try and make it easier
for you to get it close remember how I
changed these boundary varies from one
to five to remember that you can change
it again change it from two to three and
then you'll get a bit more precision on
that slide up yes because you are in a
different class at that point sorry
okay very good sir hopefully I'm gonna
try and get it with my fingers which
will be really tough hopefully you've
noticed it's almost exactly at two point
let me try and get there seven one a
little bit further over it's and you can
get closer and closer right you can
change these values to try and get as
precise as you can okay but at a certain
point they seem to sit right on top of
each other
okay now if you haven't already could
you reach for your calculator
get your calculator out of your bag I
left mine in my bag this number that you
just sort of stumbled on it's beating
your calculator this whole time
turn your calculator on right and then
what I want you to do is go all the way
to the bottom of the calculator down
where my finger is have a look at my
fingers you see middle button on the
bottom row middle middle button on the
bottom row okay so you notice there's a
couple of this probably depending on
your calculator might be slightly
different I've got a couple of different
letters above that button right ones in
red and ones in yellow do you have the
yellow number what's that it's pi right
that's not that we know that what play
is that's not pi but the other number
there the other letter rather it says a
so go ahead to get to it because red you
need to press the alpha button press the
alpha button press that and e comes up
in your display and then just hit equals
then just hit equals and you should have
a number do you see it there you got it
I'd like us all to write down the number
you see in your display write down that
number please
[Music]